hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
one perennial issue that Aristotle
examines and deals with in making ethics
one it is the connection between the
class of external goods that is goods
that are not Goods of the body or
because of soul and the nature of human
happiness and the question is this do we
need some measure of external goods in
order to be happy in the full sense in
the sense that Aristotle himself intense
this is actually to say a little bit
about the history of philosophy this is
a point on which Aristotle and the
Aristotelian took quite a bit of flack
from some of the other schools because
Aristotle is advancing a virtue ethics
we see that that happiness itself like
it but here
consists largely in virtuous activity
right not even his possession of the
virtues but actively doing things that
express that consolidated that build
perhaps even promote the virtues in
other people but there's this and
Aristotle things that you have to have
some measure of external prosperity in
order to truly
yeah so it's not really a question of
well is it wealth property or external
goods or virtue it's actually both in
although virtue is going to be more
important than the equation aerosol says
you do need some external prosperity so
some schools that said no no virtue is
the only good you can be totally poor
totally destitute deprived of friends
have everybody turned against you in
your political community but if you have
virtue you'll still be happy just as
happy and as the guy who has some you
know virtue but also he has all the
benefits of life that you could think of
so Aristotle is working through a sort
of middle path in this between those who
would say external goods are really the
most important thing and those who want
to say virtuous activity is the most
important thing he's not saying that
they're on the same level either
virtuous activity is higher and more
important as we're going to see but
external goods do matter
so you down Mia is the Greek term that
we translate by happiness and as they're
so quite stuff it's not something that
is a mere feeling that we have on a
particular time when we say I'm so happy
because somebody got me a nice balloon
and now there it goes up in the sky and
now my happiness is gone the way kids
are prone to that's not happiness and in
the full sense that Aristotle said what
you think about as fulfilment
flourishing really doing well that's
that's another way when she talks about
living well doing well so Aristotle says
that this consists largely in virtuous
activity an activity that is expressive
of that is oriented by that embodies the
virtues the excellences of characters so
courage temperance justice
you know generosity even you know having
a good sense of humor is part of that
having control over one's temper now
they don't be being truthful about
oneself friend friendliness is one of
them friendship itself is
part of the equation and so this is a
you know very robust conception of what
the good life is now the question is
does it require external goods and in
Chapter eight Aristotle gives us two
reasons two sets of reasons really if we
think about the different subject
matters why having external goods would
play some role and Happiness so if we
focus on virtuous activity and we think
about what's required in order to
exhibit the virtues we don't do them in
a total vacuum we do them in context and
sometimes they require what Aristotle
calls instruments or tools for example
if you want to be generous it's very
difficult to be generous if you don't
have any wealth at all you could do it
by getting credit cards and running up
in credit card bills but that wouldn't
actually be generosity that would be
spendthrift nasur prodigality as some of
the older translations have it because
it wouldn't be for a good purpose and it
would be putting you at risk you do
indeed in order to be generous requires
some level of material prosperity I
suppose you could be generous with your
time seeing that as something that you
have at your disposal but if we don't
even further one of the other virtues
that's similar to that is what Aristotle
calls magnificence and this is not
something that is in fact possible for
everybody because it requires that you
have significant outlay that you can put
into you might say the public display or
the public activities in order to fight
on the battlefield and exhibit courage
of the full of sense back then you
actually have to have some wealth enough
to get yourself a a shield a spear and
some armor that you had to supply so he
says some noble action some hat actions
that are expressive of virtue are going
to require wealth right some wealth
property you know resources of that
some of them were going to require that
you have friends you might not actually
have money but you have to have friends
or at least people that you're
companions with in order to exercise the
virtues that have to do with
companionship right or justice if nobody
wants to hang around with you
it's it's I suppose almost trivially
impossible to be unjust except perhaps
towards yourself because nobody will
have anything to do with you some
require that you have some political
power he actually does talk about this
in terms of do today's políticas now we
could translate that term politicus much
more broadly and say social power or
nowadays we talk in terms of social
capital so for example what we're doing
here on the internet would be an example
of the kind of power that there's that
was talking about the fact that I can't
close to 30,000 subscribers at the point
that I'm shooting this so I have a wide
range of capacity to reach people then
it provides a possibility for doing
certain virtuous activities I don't you
know want to go in too deep into to the
great detail about exactly what they
would be in terms of Arizona schema well
let's let's just put it like this the
sharing of knowledge perhaps is a kind
of generosity a large scale that's
enabled by having that platform and we
do think about all sorts of other ways
in which this plays out so in order to
be really able to do all of the virtues
and I'm not saying anybody necessarily
doesn't all the virtues but in order to
do that you would require some material
prosperity some means that you can use
you know in the case of other goods
there's sort of a negative component he
says that lacking certain goods for the
person will make the person less able to
really enjoy happiness so this is a kind
of active and this is
can it passive constraint what are these
he talked about good earth so if you are
I think you know one way to think about
this is air symbolism talk about racism
as as such but if you think about the
way racial bias works in in our modern
Western society where we've got this
long heritage of unfortunate one of
pretty horrific things and racial
clashes that have continued on down to
the present even among people who seem
to be you know relatively well disposed
in goodwill towards people they're still
implicit bias that could be like what
aerosol is talking about in terms of
birth you know hopefully we'll get
beyond that eventually children children
can be a great part of one's happiness
they can also diminish one's happiness
likewise friends if your friends are
unreliable they can make you the less
happy even though you're you're a
virtuous person in here you're
exhibiting that virtue so you know you
can think for with children of people
who are good people
and their kids somehow don't turn out to
be particularly good this is a common
problem back in Aristotle's all the time
one man Socrates actually got himself in
a bit of trouble in two generations
before for pointing out that the great
politicians the people who are has seen
that virtue somehow we're not able to
pass that on to their kids and their
kids were wrong there's somebody even
talks about good looks this is kind of
an interesting one and he might say
that's really superficial but then think
about how much people do put into
appearances and those are external goods
you know for example do you take
somebody like me as seriously if I am
you know wearing a jacket and a
button-down shirt as you would if I let
my hair down and was wearing you know
plain old flannels and looking very
scruffy you know maybe not quite so much
right good looks can be about what
you're wearing it could be
your appearance can be your faces is
symmetrical internet a little sorts of
things whether you keep your hair or
don't keep your hair plays a part
Arizona's point is a person can be in
fact happy engaged in virtuous activity
do you know if they've got some
resources if they're lacking these goods
it's not as if they're going to be
unhappy totally unhappy but they're not
going to be as happy so it does play
some role in Chapter nine he brings up
the case of crying the king of Troy who
had a pretty good life up until the time
that the Trojans messed with the Greeks
and if he finishes it up in pretty
horrible ways seeing his his son killed
his people butchered you know his
various female children taken away you
know the City Reuben pretty pretty
horrific reversal of fortune right so
all sorts of reversals of fortune can
indeed happen and they can happen not
only to the you know run-of-the-mill
people who are either virtuous or
vicious and also to people who are
vicious but to people who are virtuous
as a matter of fact your virtue itself
as we see in many narratives may attract
negative attention and have people want
to gonna trigger this well right in
chapter 10 he talks about how this plays
out in a bit more detail he says that
virtue by its nature if you really
possess virtue it's a good that is very
stable so if you really are virtuous
losing things external goods is not
going to ruin your virtue or make you
less so might ruin other goods like you
may be health unless honor
political office if you lose your money
or lose your friends so the good person
is not going to be made miserable by
losing these these good things or by
incurring bad things but they're not
going to be really happy there their
happiness is going to be marred as he
says at the same time virtue offers you
what we call resources greater is we
like to say these days resiliency in
dealing with misfortunes I want to read
you a few Piazza jizz in front of us he
says here we go the accidents of fortune
are many and varying degree of magnitude
although small pieces of good luck
clearly don't change the whole course of
life great and repeated successes will
render life more blissful but great and
frequent reverses can crush and Mar our
happiness by both the pain that they
caused and the hindrance that they offer
too many activities how many of us all
goes on it says nevertheless even in
adversity nobility shines through when a
man endures repeated and severe
misfortune with patience not going to
insensibility but from generosity and
greatness of soul so virtue by itself in
the face of misfortune is not going to
make a person completely happy but it
will still play a major role in what
measure of happiness that person has and
there's kind of a self-reinforcing
dynamic there right virtue makes you
more resilient more capable of rolling
with the punches that life is going to
deal you then the person who lacks
virtue or the person who's used even
worse life who is vicious and so it will
it won't necessarily insulate you from
the the pain that is caused or from the
deprivation you know the positive
capacities to exercise virtue but in
places you and the best canoe
no matter where you you had nothing in
the spectrum external goods you know at
the very bottom all the way up to the
very top and as a matter of fact for
those this is a little bit of a sideline
here for those who are closer to the top
the only thing that's going to keep them
from going off the rails with all of
that wealth all that power all those
capacities to engage in self-indulgence
will in fact be virtue without that
they're going to be just as lost as
anybody else at any other state so long
story short we do in fact need external
goods but external goods play only a you
might say finishing role ultimately in
happiness they they play some role but
it's not the central role that was
played by virtuous activity and that has
a sort of dynamic relationship with
those external goods